Okay.
So,
um,
we'll,
uh,
get started on the great gas man.
Um,
you know,
I'm sure that you guys have your own,
um,
views,
uh,
on,
on the novel,
So,
you know,
uh,
something to,
um,
so what I'll be talking about today is in some sense I'm kind of more of focus
or sharp edge take on guest space,
uh,
which you certainly free to dispute.
I'm in section,
uh,
but I want to begin with Maxwell Perkins and his name actually came up last
time,
uh,
when Fitzgerald read the,
in our time stories,
um,
the Paris addition,
the person who wrote to was Maxwell Perkins to say that he's the real thing.
You have to get him.
Um,
so mental Perkins obviously very,
very important.
Um,
I would say that he really is the muse of the 1920s,
um,
till the mucilage doesn't have to be a woman,
doesn't have to be a romantic relation.
He's just very,
very good reader,
careful reader,
critical reader,
as well as say.
Um,
and this is a book about Maxwell Perkins and his three sons,
um,
Fitzgerald on the,
uh,
left Hemingway in the middle.
And,
um,
Thomas Wolfe,
I'm on the right and these people wrote to him constantly.
I mean he really was their manager and Muse to all three of them.
And so Hemingway and Fitzgerald have done in common as well that they have is
great to have an editor that you know,
you're both responding to.
Um,
so anyway,
um,
Maxwell Perkins,
was the one who read the initial drafts of the Great Gas Bay and this is what he
said.
Um,
November 20th,
1924 Gatsby is somewhat vague to readers' eyes,
can ever quite focus upon him,
his outlines by them.
Now everything about gas VA is more or less than mystery.
Are you more or less vague?
And there's maybe somewhat of an artistic intention,
but I think it is mistaken.
Couldn't he be physically described as distinctly as the others and couldn't do
add one or more one or two countries stakes like the use of that phrase.
Some board,
not verbal,
but physical ones claps.
So very upfront about what he likes in this case,
what he doesn't like.
Um,
and he's also giving us the terminology,
uh,
to the loose terminology vagueness to think about the great Gatsby.
And this is what Fitzgerald says back in turned December 20th and 24 strange to
say,
my notion of great Gatsby is vagueness was,
okay,
this is a complicated idea,
but I'm sure you understand,
I know gas being better than I know my own child.
My first instinct after your leather was to let him go and have Tom.
You can dominate the book,
but the gas based sticks in my heart.
I had him for a while then lost him.
And now I know I have again just a wonderful keynote.
I think that this can have a better description of and all this relation to his
creation.
Um,
and I think that this is actually probably quite common,
you know,
feeling that you know,
this character better than you know,
your family members.
Um,
but in this case also being quite deliberate and stubborn,
um,
not in,
not giving into Maxwell Hook in the suggestion that he should make gas be less
vague.
And one other quote from Fitzgerald to Perkins,
this is much later than 1940.
Um,
I wish I was in print.
It will be odd of the year or so from now with Scott starting his daughter for
shows her friends,
I was an author and finds that no focus is procure a panel with a 25 cent press,
keep gasping and the public by,
or is the boat unpopular,
hasn't had this chance but to die so completely and unjustly after having given
so much.
Even now there is a little published in American fiction that doesn't slightly
bear my stem in a small way.
I was an original.
It's really heartbreaking that um,
that Fitzgerald and sending never knew that the great Gatsby would become the
contract boat that it is.
I mean they will be totally flabbergasted.
Um,
he,
his idea was that,
you know,
this was something that would just completely disappear.
Um,
so,
you know,
I think there we can see several things from,
um,
from this exchange.
Um,
first,
um,
is that Fitzgerald really didn't know how he spoke,
was going to end up.
Um,
you know,
so it's completely a matter of,
of hindsight that we are able to say now that this is the American classic.
Um,
he didn't know that it wasn't a classic back then.
It was experimental.
Um,
so,
you know,
we shouldn't lose sight of the fact it was an experiment and he really didn't
know if it was going to come out well or not.
In fact,
his hunch,
um,
in 94,
there was that it was going to be a failure that it couldn't go nowhere,
that wasn't going to be picked up by anyone.
It was just going to all this effort,
this,
um,
so much given to the novel,
all that was going to come to nothing.
So I think that this in itself,
uh,
suggest to us the experimental nature that he was trying something new.
Um,
and because we are so used to it now,
it in some sense it stops being new to us.
So it's very important to go back to that original sense of things being in flux
and not being sure if this was the way things were going to go.
Um,
the other interesting point about this,
uh,
leather is that Fitzgerald said that in a small way,
I was in the original,
right.
So this is not actually model the state.
Um,
I think that he's very proud of the fact that in a small,
well let me know it is mother's Day too.
But you know,
I think that he's also taking pride in the fact that,
um,
his greatness resized in the small smallness that is really in the small details
or the great Gatsby,
um,
that he would most like to be read.
Um,
so we are very much operating on the micro register today.
respecting Fitzgerald says or what kind of a of a,
of an author.
Um,
he was,
um,
and while I like to do today,
this is basically the outline for today's lecture,
um,
is to take the terminology,
uh,
from uh,
Maxwell Perkins fakeness and use a slightly more formal term,
um,
and also stretching it a little bit.
So the term I like to propose for us to consider today,
um,
as a kind of,
synonym for Wagner's,
um,
is counter realism.
Um,
you know,
we know that there's a lot that in this room mistake and the great gas way,
um,
but there's also a strain of counter realism.
And maybe that's why,
um,
it gives the impression of being vague and,
I like to tease out some of the,
um,
the,
the attributes are manifestations,
um,
of the counter real as a mode of writing.
Um,
first of all,
um,
and I will explain all this but this,
the desire to,
uh,
Captain Lotion,
this is actually something,
um,
that was done in 19th century photography to Garrow type trying to catch them in
motion.
This was started actually,
um,
very much,
by using machines and you know,
the early camera to capture motion.
And I think that,
um,
uh,
Fitzgerald was trying to do something like that,
integrate gas player.
Um,
and now they're,
um,
component of this counter realism is a,
the uncertain boundaries between animate and inanimate and related to that human
attributes,
properties of the,
of human personalities are properties of the human body,
um,
being channeled or routed through our properties.
So the machine.
Um,
and then the two,
going back to our discussion of comedy and tragedy,
um,
there's a variety of high tech comedy and variety of hires had tragedy and
there's novel,
but they also interconnected.
So,
um,
let's first look at,
what Fitzgerald is trying to do and motion a,
but I thought that I'll just give you a completely static image.
Okay.
Of the mansion.
Um,
um,
this is the Guggenheim managed,
movie as we mentioned that she went to a wedding there at your friends,
your senior prom.
Okay.
Um,
so,
um,
and uh,
the,
so this is,
you can go and visit.
Um,
but,
um,
I mean this is the Guggenheim Mansion,
so you know,
is over the top.
Um,
but this is the nature of the,
you know,
of those managers,
um,
at cents point or East Asia where Tom and daisy,
uh,
live.
Um,
and so this is a very static,
very impressive but static image of a mansion.
Um,
let's see what,
how Fitzgeral,
um,
describes the,
uh,
that,
you can mention
lawn started at the beach and ran to what the front lawn for quarter of a mile
jumping over sun dials and break was and burning gardens.
Finally when they reach the house drifting up the side in bright vines as though
from the momentum of this run is lately not a static disruption at all.
Um,
you know,
they,
they are,
there's a little bit of static description of what the house looks like,
but I think that this is really what jumps out at us is the translation of a
static physical object into motion.
This is not even trying to capture something that is actually moving,
uh,
but trying to attribute motion to something that is otherwise stationary and
static.
Um,
and um,
we don't know yet.
I mean this is quite early so we don't quite know why Fitzgerald would choose to
write in this way.
But definitely this is a very,
very deliberate way of writing.
So it makes sure that keep that in mind is that there's quite often a kind of
conversion conversion takes place all the time in Fitzgerald her,
we've see the,
he couldn't lose,
uh,
qualities are sung into visual images and he also can verse stationary objects
into moving objects.
Um,
so there's a quality of,
um,
this much suddenly much more dynamic.
Um,
but it also gives a sense that,
um,
even right here,
we can say that it's almost as if the lion has agency,
right?
It's not just sitting there.
Um,
it's not just a Alonda there's mobilize on one.
it actually is start somewhere.
It goes some place.
Uh,
it jumps over things.
Um,
it generates its own momentum.
So the leaves we can say is that inanimate objects have live and motion in
agency.
And that has tremendous implications both for those inanimate objects and
possibly also animate objects like human beings.
You know,
when you have inanimate objects taking on the properties of Adam,
that human beings,
um,
what happens to the human beings who supposedly in possession of those
properties.
Um,
so,
you know,
this is just a kind of very,
this is not a dramatic moment.
Um,
it,
but it says a lot about the kind of strategy,
um,
the Fitzgerald uses.
Um,
so let's go on now and look more at the boundaries between the animate and
inanimate,
because I think this was really a kind of a major strategy,
um,
perform throughout the great gas.
Um,
so this is an image of corona,
which is the original,
uh,
for the Valley of ashes.
Um,
that,
um,
Fitzgerald describes some way and um,
this,
there's no man's land,
um,
even in this kind of very desolate,
a visual image,
uh,
but still,
um,
you know,
still we can visualize a such a place.
Um,
there's lit as it is.
let's look at the way Fitzgerald describes this place.
About halfway between west a and New York,
the motor row hastily joins the railroad and runs beside it for water of a mile,
so as to shrink away from the southern desolate area of land.
This is a valley of ashes.
A fantastic farm were ashes,
grow like weed into ridges and hills and grew tennis gardens were ashes.
Take the forms of houses and chimneys and rising smoke.
And finally with the transcendent effort of men who moved,
move Lee and already crumbling through the powdery air,
occasionally align of gray cars,
cross long and invisible track gives out a ghastly creek and comes to rest.
And immediately to ask Raymond swam up with lead in space and stare up and
impenetrable Clough which screens of skill operations from your site?
I honestly don't know what Fitzgerald is talking about,
whether he's really talking about actual ash.
Gray men wore those men.
They don't look like people who work at gas stations.
We just don't know what they are.
Um,
so by the end,
by the time we get to the end of the passage to ontological status of the
passage is really in depth.
We don't know if this is just hallucination.
Um,
if this is an optical illusion or you know,
something even worse than that hallucination on a pot of nick.
Um,
so,
um,
the,
we can now see,
um,
the fact that inanimate objects have agency and are capable of moving,
that they tend to render the visual few free,
wildly a very shaky.
It's quite often our focus,
um,
quite often this like a camera than this moving is blurry image.
Um,
so we don't exactly know what we're looking at.
but even though we can exactly say we can name the thing that we're looking at,
um,
there is something grotesque about this scene,
right?
Just,
and the grotesqueness comes not so much,
uh,
from the landscape itself,
um,
in the original landscape.
You know,
it's just sad,
but it's not especially a grotesque.
The grotesqueness comes really completely from Fitzgerald's rhetoric,
from his rhetorical intensification of that landscape.
Um,
ashes growing like weed,
um,
and into ridges and hills and grotesque Gordon's ashes,
taking the form of houses and so on.
And maybe ash is turning into those ash gray man.
You know,
maybe they are just optical illusions.
They're not really biological human beings.
We don't know.
Um,
so it seems as if this kind of grotesque for candidate,
uh,
to inanimate objects,
ashes are capable of reproduction.
They're capable of reproducing themselves in a way that we tend to think that
only animate things are capable of doing right.
With reduction is not a property is now the prerogative of inanimate objects.
But here it seems as if it actually is within the province of enameled objects
to be grotesquely reproductive.
Um,
so this,
this,
um,
already what we're beginning to say is the cons,
the right thing over,
um,
have a lot of the things that we had imagined to be on the human side,
the human side that you equation that all those things that we have,
um,
you know,
that are in our possession,
that we are the sole owners of all those things have been written over,
um,
to inanimate objects that may or may not be benign towards us.
We don't really know what the relation is between this inanimate objects,
um,
and us.
But there's another,
I think there's yet another twist to this,
um,
to this,
passage.
Um,
and it has to do with a fury on obtrusive.
Uh,
but I will say nontrivial,
um,
phrase,
which is the re the motor row hastily joins the railroad and runs beside for
quarter of a mile.
Um,
do you guys remember anything?
I'm hearing that phrase before
the law started and the beach and ran to what the front lawns or quarter of a
mile.
So this is the kind of verbal echo,
um,
bad of a very small battalion.
Did how Dan suggested those two passages are connected.
I mean,
you know,
we can really see what kind of a craftsman he is a genius in a small way,
but you know,
that's why he's so great,
um,
is that it's just this completely factual,
seemingly factual phrase that serves as the bond between those two passages.
So the suggestion was,
seemed to be that there's kind of an underside to that you can garden right in a
mansion grand mansion in the ons on,
um,
that this is really under sy.
Um,
and in fact,
the two of them actually have a lot in common.
There's a lot of common ground and the live the strange and obscure but very
thorough,
um,
and managing live of the inanimate object,
which seem to be the common ground between those two.
So,
you know,
we,
we don't have to read very far,
um,
into Greg Gatsby to know that there's something very wrong with that marriage
between Tom and daisy.
Um,
and,
um,
if this,
the landscape itself suggests that the desolation is never really absent from,
from that household.
Um,
so I know that we are all thinking about Gatsby because really,
um,
Maxwell Perkins,
objected mostly to the portrait of gas where the,
he's very vague.
So here is this 1974,
uh,
version,
um,
and Bali by Robert Redford of gas bed.
Um,
and you know,
as you say,
um,
when I see it as it is,
is,
it's not,
I wouldn't say it's not,
not my image of guests.
We are,
but there's also not my image of Gatsby either because I really hadn't really
visualized,
gets me all that much.
So you know,
I have it from co funding in relation to this.
Um,
I mean is okay.
but I guess I really could do without him.
But anyway,
it's,
um,
it is,
uh,
interesting,
um,
kind of foil to what Fitzgerald is trying to do because I don't,
I mean,
you know,
suddenly was which you see the movie and everything,
but,
um,
the book is trying to do something very different.
It's not trying to create the Robert Redford like image,
um,
of gasping.
So this is,
um,
why,
Maxwell Perkins,
um,
things that,
uh,
Gas Bay is vague it personality,
it's an unbroken series of successful gestures.
Then there was something gorgeous about him,
some heightened sensitivity to the promises of live as if he would relate it to
one of those intricate machines that register earthquakes 10,000 miles away.
There's almost no physical description.
This is very early.
It's true.
We haven't seen Gatsby,
but there really is never a full flesh physical description of gas pay.
Um,
and is that we get this very,
very ugly,
very abstract,
uh,
descriptions of gas where,
um,
telling him,
telling us,
um,
about his person now are they are,
but not even suppliers with adjectives.
Um,
to name that.
So,
you know,
we can just look at the simple level of syntax.
Um,
is hedging is Securitas is in the condition.
Old Hands,
right?
If begins with the word,
if,
if who's now at least on unbroken series.
So right there is not even a declarative sentence as a conditional sentence if,
and then construction.
Um,
so,
you know,
it's not nick,
it's not even fully committed,
committed himself to that description.
Um,
he's,
he is holding back to some degree.
Um,
and not only that,
not only is this kind of very obtrusive conditionality,
um,
to the syntax,
uh,
but then out of nowhere this,
this disruption that he's related to this machine seismograph a machine that
registered earthquakes 10,000 miles away.
You know,
it really isn't a very vivid analogy.
Ally's no graphic analogy.
Gaspe does not look in the least like that kind of machine.
Right?
You know,
we don't know what he looks like,
but we know for sure it doesn't look like one of those machines.
So it is not an analogy that isn't helping us to visualize gas.
Gaspe um,
and quite the contrary is making it.
So that's why I think that,
you know,
the movie is really its own entity.
I mean it's not really,
uh,
related to the book is totally different medium.
Um,
this is the linguistic medium that,
um,
that Fitzgerald is working with and trying to do something different.
So,
um,
it,
you know,
and I was,
I have to say it is an open question.
I mean some of us actually are more stimulated by the visual medium than by the
linguistic medium.
So,
you know,
I'm not saying here that you know that the movie is inferior to the novel.
Um,
but I do think that we have to,
uh,
be sure to give the linguistic medium is too in the sense that it really is
trying to do something different.
Um,
so,
um,
we don't,
you know,
no.
Uh,
what,
what gas bay is like other than that,
um,
he is some,
one who seems to be working with a green would be able to work with great
distances.
You know,
I think a registered,
um,
and earthquakes 10,000 miles away.
I mean that is really not a skill or talent that is necessary in the great
Gatsby,
no earthquakes and Greg aspects.
But there is,
um,
something,
that caused for kind of a long distance tenacity and persistence,
which is actually across time to enable it to be faithful to one idea.
So it's not 10,000 miles away,
but over a number of years remaining stubbornly attached to that one idea of a
woman.
Um,
so there's right there,
there's also a kind of,
um,
substitution or transposition,
of,
um,
of a temporal attributes onto a special attribute as well.
But in any case,
uh,
but not completely pinning guests be down.
Um,
I think the fifth Gero is really inviting us to project our own meaning a or
project our own reading of gas.
Bear into this very,
very loosely assemble,
very pointed,
but oddly enough pointed,
but not focus is a paradox.
But I think that that's really the effect that Fitzgerald is trying to
cultivate.
So,
um,
we,
uh,
we spend quite a bit of time,
talking about comedy and a tragedy.
Um,
last last couple of classes.
and I want to,
uh,
bring those back and um,
talk a little bit once again,
uh,
about them as a mixture,
um,
that,
they're not too very discrete hours.
Um,
in the three authors that we're reading,
um,
they tend to be,
crossover,
um,
very much,
crossover genres in,
in,
in the Greg aspect.
Um,
and in here because the inanimate,
because machines are so important in this novel,
um,
comedy is quite often a channeled through,
high tech gadgets.
Um,
and here is one of the kind of very local,
very basically just right there.
Um,
instance of comedy.
every Friday,
five trays of oranges and lemons arrived from a footer in New York.
Every Monday the same oranges and lemons laugh his back door and a pyramid or
publishers house.
There was a machine in the kitchen which could extract the juice of 200 oranges
and half an hour if a little button was pressed 200 times by Buffalo's thumb.
Um,
so I think that Cisco was having fun,
uh,
where there's,
um,
there's this comedy both as it comes to us,
but also comedy in the act of conversation.
I mean,
there's obviously an author,
it was having grits,
good time writing about this.
Um,
so the reduction of the Butler to just his thumb and the thumb read do use once
more to a completely utilitarian function oppressing this pattern out 200 times
in half an hour and producing the effect on our oranges.
Um,
so this is,
this is hilarious.
It's not,
I mean,
I guess it's terrible if we think about it from the Butler's point of view that
this is what he has to do.
Um,
but,
um,
I mean maybe it's kind of repetitive,
monotonous,
kind of terrible kind of labor really.
If we think that that's what we have to do,
but as Fisher is telling the story is really not supposed to be a tragic,
um,
is comic.
Although the,
I would say that the tragedy,
all these phenomenon of,
uh,
of just kind of unbearable,
kind of repetitive labor is actually not so far away from it either.
Um,
that is the nature of comedy here.
so we'll move on the bed little machine,
even though it's memorable,
it's,
it's not a star player in the great Gatsby.
The telephone is a star player.
Um,
and this is an image,
um,
of,
just what the telephone,
very glamorous looking machine.
Very beautiful.
Um,
so you can see that,
why people with one to you know,
right.
Works of literature about such a beautiful machine.
Um,
and before we get to you guys know,
I'm going to talk about that phone ringing,
you know,
when the Buchanans having dinner,
right?
So,
um,
we'll get there.
But for now I just want to have a little detour,
um,
by way of the great poet who's also,
who mostly is known for,
is writing about nature and is not known for his writing about technology.
Robert Frost.
Um,
but Robert Frost,
Ashley has a poem called the telephone and I think it's very,
very useful counterpoint actually,
um,
to first Gero and you see whether he's really talking about the telephone.
The title of the poem is the telephone.
Um,
and quite often in frost is this is a dramatic dialogue,
dialogue between two people having found with flour and driven to be away.
I leaned my head and holding by the storm,
I listen and I thought I caught the world.
Who is it that you call me by my name?
Or did you say someone said,
come,
I heard it as I bow.
I may have thought as much but not allow.
Well,
so in Cannes,
so it's a lovely poem.
Um,
as a love.
It's a love poem about two people who are in love.
Um,
we don't know the gender actually,
I think it's Atlanta.
The one,
um,
is someone really wanting to see right.
And just taking,
finding a skews to come and see that person claiming that,
um,
that,
that he's hearing a voice telling him to come.
And that is the telephone ubiquitination marks.
Uh,
the froze,
he knows about the telephone,
but he's really not talking about the machine.
He's talking about,
um,
the kind of impalpable,
uh,
kind of,
um,
audio,
uh,
audible barn or the Bank of Ireland on ability,
um,
that that just brings out one person to the presence of another person.
Um,
and uh,
that is the telephone line.
It's that emotional core that really binds one person and that is the most
powerful telephone line of or,
um,
so it's a lovely upon and it's very much humanizing the telephone,
giving,
uh,
turn,
turning it into an emotion,
a romantic context,
uh,
charged with human that you motions.
Uh,
and it's really the fact that it's the carrier of human emotions that makes the
telephone such an important human vehicle.
It is completely has been completely assimilated into the everyday world of just
human intimacy.
Um,
so,
um,
let's see what Fitzgerald does.
Uh,
with the telephone,
the telephone rang inside stuff me and as daisy shook her head decisively at
time,
the subject of the stables,
in fact,
pause objects vanish into hair amount of broken fragments of the last five
minutes a table.
I remember the candles being lit up again when Leslie and I was conscious of a
one of wanting to look squarely at everyone and yet to avoid all eyes.
I couldn't guess with daisy and Tom were thinking,
but I doubt if even this Baker who seem to have mastered so in skepticism was
able only to put the fifth gas shrill metallic version and see,
oh my,
so on the other end of the spectrum from Robert Frost means surprisingly
actually,
because he's on the other side of the spectrum,
actually the telephone actually is also charged with enhanced emotions.
You know,
this is not just a machine.
So,
you know,
we can almost say,
we can almost always say that machines are,
uh,
always,
um,
carriers of human emotions in one way or another.
And that's why they are important.
Uh,
machines.
I mean,
if they were just like that button that the Butler presence were there,
some,
um,
you know,
it's just a,
wouldn't you know,
be a very presence at all.
But the telephone is a very important presence and the great Gatsby.
Um,
and what's interesting about this particular scenario,
um,
constructed around this high tech machine in the 19 20th is the association.
Uh,
we have the of this high tech machine with an intrusive for us into a
traditional household.
Right before the telephone rang.
It was a pleasant dinner.
Um,
and um,
they say,
and Tom and her cousin,
nick and good friend,
Jordan Baker all saying down to a very civilized,
um,
dinner.
Um,
and in the course of that civilized dinner,
suddenly the appearance of barbarian hordes,
uh,
that was mentioned by Tom,
right?
Because been reading this book about the rise of the color empires.
So this,
the first intrusion of somebody not wanted,
um,
but not quite dismissible,
you know,
that is not a trivial,
uh,
reference because Ashley,
they see them,
picks it up and talks about her white girlhood and so on.
So the rise of the colored empire by Goda,
that,
um,
God.
Dot that Tom has been reading that actually first intrusive,
uninvited guests.
It's just a book,
but it's very much was an uninvited guest to the dinner.
Um,
and then there's a second uninvited guests coming by way of the telephone.
so,
you know,
we can say there's a causal relation between them.
You know,
it's not as if the telephone was always bringing in people from a different
social class really.
Um,
and we know later,
um,
that that,
murder was calling here,
um,
is of such a unacceptable social class even though she's okay as a mistress is
not okay for her to manage than Daisy's name.
Right.
When she mentioned Stacy's name Tom Bricks,
who knows.
So,
you know,
that is the taboo that um,
Tom would not allow [inaudible] um,
to break,
um,
someone like her has no right to mention his wife's name that comes later.
Right now,
all we know is that there's a lot of mailers on the part of,
um,
of Murdo.
You don't,
cause if you want to talk to someone discreetly,
you don't call during dinner time.
Um,
so it was a call that comes bearing mallows to begin with.
and it's met with,
uh,
well I mean mallows or just have the luxury of being able to ignore,
which is the luxury that,
um,
the,
the freedom that I'm facing.
Um,
and,
um,
uh,
something at this moment.
Um,
so,
um,
all the sort of social antagonisms,
that are kind of bubbling actually be,
we need the service on the great Gatsby.
Uh,
all those antagonisms,
uh,
being,
um,
foregrounded,
uh,
by version of this high tech machine.
Um,
so,
um,
and we also shouldn't forget,
I mean this is a book,
um,
the Greek gas basin,
not a book about race.
We have to be very careful,
um,
that,
is,
is even though this reverence arise as the color empires,
it's not primarily about race,
but race is also not unimportant.
Um,
in the great Gatsby,
which is very,
very strange to me.
Somebody should write a paper about this,
uh,
beginning with the reference to rise with color and why essentially a persistent
on the current,
uh,
of,
um,
of blackness actually and,
in,
in this novel.
Um,
so,
um,
as there's also is the kind of an undercurrent of German,
is that gas based supposed to be in the pay of the German army?
It's supposed to be a cousin of the Kaiser.
Um,
oh,
there was a really,
really kill it and quite insistent.
So you know,
as you go on to write papers,
you know,
something to know this,
it's very marginal references.
Um,
they are not trivial.
So,
um,
let's look now at the ferry.
Um,
the really the stop play or the star high tech player who's going to be the star
player all the way through the Great Gas Bay,
which is the car.
And um,
you should call it automobile dignify a name.
Um,
so here's the automobile.
and this is the 1920s Rose Royce.
Um,
and this actually is a pretty good representation,
or at least this is the car,
um,
that,
uh,
that um,
that was used in the,
uh,
in the great.
Um,
and we see nick and uh,
Gatsby there,
Sam Waterston,
a snake,
a rubber effort.
Uh,
so it looks very much like that car.
And,
um,
to get a better view of the roast rise to me,
you know,
sorry.
Um,
I have do all respectfully Rose Rose,
but this doesn't seem like a very impressive,
the eco,
I mean,
you know,
I can work up some excitement about it,
but,
um,
it's not,
I wouldn't say it's really bad.
Stunning.
Um,
sorry,
uh,
because it looks more steadily move human beings in it.
Um,
but other hoe,
I mean there's just a car.
Um,
but here,
here is,
um,
Fitzgerald,
his description of the Rose Royce and I had seen,
and everybody has seen it.
It was a rich cream color,
right?
With Nicco swollen here and there and this monstrous lane with triumph and had
boxes and suffered boxes and two boxes and to Harris with a lever in of
windshields that mirror but doesn't sons saying down behind many layers of glass
in the sort of green leather conservatory.
He started to town is not a description of that car?
No,
no.
I mean,
this is pure fabrication on Fitzgerald's pot.
Um,
and,
uh,
if there's a kind of a reference back to classical mythology to elaborate,
um,
I mean,
I don't know what cognitive elaboration of wind shows.
Um,
so it seems that,
you know,
Fisher is not really talking about a cost so much as just an occasion to use the
classical mythology.
And this is in fact the stuff that modern,
um,
mythology is made of.
You know,
this is the car is the heart and soul of Marlin and Tana mythology and is high
tech mythology that this is what enables us to create myths about ourselves and
about other human beings that we're intrigued.
But so in many ways,
um,
this is Nick's tribute to this completely mysterious,
and uh,
and,
and seemingly super human,
um,
person or not super human in the,
he's better than all of us,
but in the sense that he's not quite human,
both maybe some and superhuman,
but combined,
um,
that there's something about him that there,
he's just not like the rest of us.
Um,
and so as a consequence of gas bay,
um,
not being quite like the rest of us,
his car also has to be not quite like anything else on earth really.
It has to be this,
this,
um,
basically this creature of language.
Uh,
but what is also interesting is that there's a kind of virus gesture.
I didn't attempt to go back Ashley,
um,
to that original image of the Valley of ashes and the group fecundity uh,
of the ashes.
Um,
inanimate objects are capable of reproduction here.
The car is a green leather conservatory.
Um,
we don't know what vegetation is in that conservatory.
It could be that it is not,
obviously it's not real vegetation.
Um,
it is whatever's growing in gas baby's heart rate,
you know,
that there is something has to be growing there in order for it to survive all
those years.
Um,
and oddly enough,
whatever's growing there,
um,
can be preserved and knowledge,
knowledge only by high tech machines,
um,
that he gets base is very much a self made man.
Um,
and he's also self and making a particular kind of romantic relation.
Uh,
but the nourishment,
um,
that,
that kind of self making needs is actually high tech system sustenance,
high temp maintenance and high tech sustenance.
Um,
so,
um,
in all these ways,
you know,
we can see that,
um,
the,
the inanimate has taken over and is really a contributing,
um,
and shedding the human world.
I want to end with,
um,
two more,
images of the automobile.
Um,
and uh,
this is looking ahead.
Um,
and the first one is,
um,
very,
marginal and not especially noticeable,
uh,
detail.
Um,
that I think that we should in fact try to notice and try to do something with.
this is when,
um,
uh,
nick is,
is it's uh,
going to New York,
um,
uh,
with Tom.
Um,
a deadman pass as in a horse,
he would bloons um,
followed by two carriages,
withdrawn blinds and buy more cheerful carriages for friends.
As we cross Blackwell's island.
They mostly in past us driven by what she'll four in which said three mothers
Nehru's to bugs and the go,
I left Blau as the use of the Ibos road towards us.
Qualitative bribery isn't really what I mean by race being a very unexpected on
the current,
in the great Gatsby.
Um,
this really is a completely unnecessary detail.
the will never say that the most thing driven by the way she'll for,
uh,
where the three with the two black men and the
young black girl,
a black woman,
uh,
sitting in that car.
Um,
I mean the suit reverse or of the of the,
the iconic image of what a skin color,
uh,
the chauffeur usually is odd and it was the skin color that people would use.
It usually sitting in the limo saying,
um,
so a complete reversal of the color scheme of inside of the Muesli and um,
and um,
but even though that's a striking visual,
um,
detail it is not necessary.
Um,
there's no obviousness Acetate for his placement in the novel.
So we do,
this is one instance where something is,
um,
I would say is under determined in the sense that the passage right there,
in fact,
the rest of the novel is not giving us an adequate explanation.
Under determined not enough information is given to,
was to enable us to make sense of this particular moment in the novel.
Um,
the only way we can make sense of it as true interpretation.
So,
you know,
interpretation,
interpretations,
actually unnecessary link,
um,
in all for this passage to make sense,
uh,
to be an organic part of the novel.
So,
you know,
I would argue that in some sense raised is being,
um,
uh,
a dues from times,
um,
as a kind of a visual analog,
to,
um,
people crossing class boundaries,
that there's something,
there's an apple transgression or kind of a reversal of social hierarchy,
um,
modal,
uh,
intruding into the dinner of her social betters.
You know,
and I'm using that,
um,
phrase deliberately,
that you know,
that that has to be included in ours.
But the offense,
Paula,
the offense of,
of murderers that she,
she really should keep stick to social stations,
stick to the place,
and she was intruding into this private space of a social barriers.
Um,
and in some sense this the same kind of a transgression,
uh,
intrusion or reversal of the traditional hierarchies.
Um,
in the three African Americans being driven by a ships chauffeur.
So all of that is,
is,
is almost a Fitzgerald can't really talk about it.
Um,
in,
in terms of gas state,
you know,
who's actually the person was responsible,
most responsible for that kind of transgression.
Um,
and Gatsby is really related to murder in that way.
I mean we think about who gets killed at Amazon novel.
That is one bond between Caspian model,
uh,
but there are numerous other bonds between them and raise the kind of uh,
Ooh,
leak.
Um,
transfer ratio.
Transposition Ashley is one of the common grounds between gas being loyal.
Um,
so this is a very intriguing moment,
um,
in the,
in the Greg [inaudible].
Um,
and this is just to round up,
um,
what we,
no,
I mean in the ending of,
I mean the plot of the great Gatsby.
I don't think I'm giving anything away.
Um,
this is actually the moment when fish actually uses the word charge.
Are they,
um,
the Dev car as the newspaper would call it didn't stop.
It came out of the gathering darkness waiver tragically for moment and then
disappear around the next Ben,
uh,
we know that this is the moment where Mergel gets killed in this course.
She's sorry,
rather,
uh,
I mean it's,
the book doesn't really rests on that,
that one detail.
You can know it and still,
you know,
that's right knowledge.
Um,
but this is what happens to Morocco.
and um,
in some sense this really,
um,
there's an echoing already.
Um,
those,
uh,
that man,
you know,
who knows.
Um,
and uh,
in,
in that previous,
um,
passage about automobile,
and in this passage that was just a completely,
uh,
you know,
in conspicuous referenced that it just happened to be a host.
Um,
in the second mention of the car,
um,
it actually is a real horse,
not in the sense that there's a dead body in it.
Um,
but in the sense that is the carrier of del Vista bringer conveyor of death to
Morocco.
So we can get a sense of what the careful writer for Cheryl is.
Right.
You know,
this is really,
he is someone who works over at your house over and over again,
so that they all this intricate into connections,
um,
in the novel.
Um,
and in that way,
even though it is not as complicated,
is not,
it is every bit as complicated as fuck.
Like,
it's not as difficult to with,
you know,
on the phase of it as,
as Faulkner,
but it's an Aba that we should read over and over again as well,
just to get all those echos and interrelations.
Um,
so we'll come back on Thursday and wrap up the Greek aspect.